[Music]
before I decided to be a musician I
thought I was gonna be a scientist and
that's what I love that's one of the
main reasons why this is so so
significant to me just to be working on
the students and to be at MIT
Miguel's Anton is alto saxophonist
composer hailing from Puerto Rico a
Guggenheim and MacArthur Fellow and one
of the most important jazz musicians of
our time he has really set the music
world on fire with his fantastic ability
to fuse melody harmony and rhythm in a
very special and innovative way
we have this great composer great artist
and he wants to try out this idea where
he talks to a few students about their
research and he tries to incorporate
that into the music that he composes
they complain exactly as it is that's
cool but also it could be loose just
kind of play it off that okay one of
those sections is gonna have to repeat
we're gonna make it like go okay before
this before okay I met with Miguel at
Dunkin Donuts and we spoke about the
public service projects I had been doing
most recently the thing that really sort
of blew me away was this like this the
devotion that she had that's sort of
like her calling you know they really
just looking for ways to be of service
the main title is a music service and it
comes from a quote from Kyla you know
it's like music is part of what they
have to offer
I really love that title because I think
it just is so true music as like a
service to the community as a service to
individuals the music has served me like
enormous ly
[Music]
the first movement is properties and is
the movement that came out of the
conversation with Hana
Anna was working with properties of
carbon nanotubes when we're reinforcing
the material we add in the materials in
some material that already exists in
different orientations so that can
change the conductivity of a material as
well as the toughness seeing what we can
do with materials in general what kind
of weird properties you can find and use
[Music]
to me what I told me it was like you
have like a smaller fast moving layer
within it's a larger layer you know so
musically I was trying to portray that
on the piece and actually went into the
molecular structure of carbon to
translate into numbers and music to
write a lot of piece
the rhythm is so crazy I was like what
is going on like what did he see and and
what did I tell him
[Music]
even the name of it kind of came as a
surprise to me and I think it's not
until today that I realized oh wow like
I'm seeing properties a lot but that
totally makes sense
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the second movement is humanity humanity
that's the movement that comes from the
trio of Elisabeth Karina and Joseph
[Music]
I'm a graduate student MIT I study urban
planning and transportation and what
really fascinates me is how we can bring
innovation into urban mobility there's
very few studies on taxis it's just not
a sexy thing to study so we did a pretty
thorough diagnostic on the industry what
is the relationship like what is the
power dynamics like what is the drivers
working conditions what is the
relationship between drivers and
passengers the study is called a
humanizing travel
[Music]
urban studies and planning is all about
how do you make cities work for the
people who live in them I focus mostly
on environmental policies so that's both
how do we make sure that we don't
destroy the planet that sustains all of
us and also how do you deal with the
very real sort of equity concerns that
come when you're talking about
environmental policy
[Music]
we were investigating electoral
accountability we took survey data from
around the country from the past 40
years and we tried to see how well it
correlated with the public public policy
around the country and this is all in
regards to energy and environmental
policy
[Music]
Josie and Karina and Elizabeth they were
all in the hallway dealing with
different ways to help save the planet
you know basically
[Music]
the third movement is entitled syntax
that came out of the conversation that I
had with Wendy we do some language
studies and I was interested in looking
at like how kids perceive transitive
verbs whether or not they understand
that there's like a cause and an action
in the sentence if you order the words
in a certain way our kids going to
perceive it differently
[Music]
Miguel took that ideas sentence
structure and really ran with it with
syntax
what I did was I actually took snippets
of what she said and transcribed the
rhythm of it you know and then like put
notes to that rhythm and that rhythm
would become sort of like a section of a
piece and I orchestrated that section
for the whole band
[Music]
[Music]
he sent me an email saying can you check
these quotes from the interview that I
had with you they may be useful to what
I'm writing in the piece and then they
ended up in the music so I wasn't really
expecting that
[Music]
that was pretty surreal hearing everyone
say my words back to me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I think my movement service really was
true to what I spoke to make all about
[Music]
a quasi-religious guy and made me think
about that experience that sort of dogma
of going to church and the music you
hear at church and how that kind of
brings you to a special place so as I
was writing her piece I was thinking of
that trying to recreate that feeling
that I was getting from music that does
do more with gospel
[Music]
I chose to work on projects related to
food insecurity and homelessness in our
community
I thought it was a good opportunity to
raise attention to the needs that I'm
trying to address with my public service
my hope would be that others would see
you know this piece was written about Oh
some MIT student that was working on
these causes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I feel like this experience that we're
having with this commission is a perfect
example of calling response we have
fantastic artist comes MIT and wants to
have a conversation with students at
your conversation calling response and
he sits down with us he hears what we
have to say and then each movement is
sort of his response
[Music]
I just get so much out of playing and
ensembles playing on my own on the piano
it's a great way to like kind of relax
it's an emotional outlet when you are
happy you can pick up your instrument
and play a happy song when you're sad
you can play a long slow piece
[Music]
it's not a conservatory buy we don't
spend all of our time in the practice
room but I think that that helps because
it makes that time that you do get to
spend playing music so precious it's in
kind of looks like how often do you come
across a situation where such different
fields are kind of blended together it's
so artistic it's a great experience I'm
really grateful for it the second last
note yeah the tuba in the euphonium that
should be a b-flat d-flat I mean anybody
that's playing that note but soon should
stay there yeah oh and be natural yeah
okay I think it's amazing when we can
find cross-pollination and integration
between the arts and science science and
technology which is what most of us do
at MIT I probably will never play
professionally but I really really want
to continue playing for as long as I
possibly can I might have to scale down
to a smaller instrument at some point
but I want to continue playing and I
want to see sort of where it takes me
because
I've had really great opportunities
through it so far
[Music]